bachelor nation your new bachelor has
been named the announcement was made on
Good Morning America Tuesday morning the
night before fans watched as the 26 year
old former football player dumped his
girlfriend Tia booth on bachelor in
paradise I just know what you deserve I
can't give it to you
we're trying to cuddle
after all those tears Colton then
explained why he's ready to be the
bachelor one thing that I took pride in
on both seasons is just being true to
who I am
mm-hmm and I think it took all of that
to get to where I'm at now and know who
I am as a person and know what I want in
a life partner Underwood says he is
prepared to find a wife but some fans
questioned the choice on Twitter here's
what his ex TIA
told et him potentially being The
Bachelor how would you feel about that I
mean it was just
when do we film that June I mean it was
just about two months ago that I was
telling him that he really needs to
figure himself out before he can fully
be with someone else so if there's a
chance that Colton is the bachelor I
would hope that he is fully ready for
that experience knowing that he wants to
be engaged at the end of it do you think
he's ready
I vote Jason for bachelor so you don't
think Cole is ready we haven't really
had those conversations since paradise
obviously it's been guys have been
talking every day I don't know that he's
ready I don't
you